1, 2, 3, 4
I think one thing I was thinking about a lot was just my speed, because I realized I was going a little too fast, so just being able to control my pace and make sure I'm controlling my movements.
Also my foot placement as well, just making sure that my stances are long enough and they're pointed in the right directions.
Because a lot of the times it's very much muscle memory, but still I'm just trying to remember what the movements are, because I just don't do this pomse that often, or pomse at all that often.
So I've been trying to think about how I can just keep it as long as I can.
I've been working on my back, which is a little bit more difficult, I think, a lot.
I'm not sure if I can do that, but I'm just gonna keep it as long as I can.
Then I'll try to get my hands on the top of my head right now, and I want to see how far I can go.
I'm not sure if I can do it in a good way, but I just want to see how far I can go.
I was also thinking about a lot of things I could do in a short time, so I'll try to do them all, and then I'll just keep going.
1, 2, 3, 4